- [Female Narrator] What is Synesthesia?
Everybody who has it experiences
it in different ways,
so I asked a handful of
people from around the world
about their experience.
- [Male Respondent] Somewhere in my brain,
the senses get mixed together.
When I experience one, I'm
also experiencing another
that is completely unrelated.
- [Female Narrator] What do you mean?
- [Male Respondent] I color
code numbers in my head.
- [Female Respondent]
So, ever since I was a child,
I was able to taste words.
- [Female Participant]
If I'm in physical pain,
I experience the pain in color and shape.
- [Female Interviewee] Sounds,
melodies, and, in fact,
soundtracks also has a color to me.
- [Female Narrator] What
sort of associations
would you make?
- [Female Participator]
The number three is blue.
- [Female Respondent]
Number three is light blue.
- [Male Respondent] Three is yellow.
- [Female Interviewee]
Number six is a flirty woman.
- [Male Respondent] Four
is green, two is red.
42 is green-red.
That's my favorite number, because I like
the colors red and green together.
- [Female Narrator] But
wait, it gets weirder.
- [Female Interviewee] For example,
I loved Flashdance songs.
She's a Maniac is blue one for me,
but What a Feeling is yellow.
- [Female Respondent] Word
people tastes like meatballs
in tomato sauce.
- [Female Contributor] Violins
as navy blue rectangles
moving from right to left.
- [Female Respondent] The
word English tastes like
a slice of lemon.
The sound of banjos tastes like Oreos.
- [Female Narrator] Crazy, right?
But a life without it?
- [Female Interviewee] Hmm,
my life without Synthesia
I don't want to imagine it.
More empty.
- [Female Participator] My
life would be a lot more bland.
- [Female Contributor] The
world would be very flat
and not as colorful.
- [Male Respondent] I would be bored.